and today we are broadcasting from one
of New York's best maternity Wards the
reason is that about nine hours ago I
became the mother of this little girl
Michaela Katarina she's fine I'm fine my
husband thinks I'm crazy to be doing
this but as they say the show must go on
a little bit later
that's veteran TV host Deborah Norville
anchoring Inside Edition from her own
hospital bed after giving birth talk
about a superwoman yeah it's just one of
the many memorable moments from the show
we're just celebrating its launch on
this day back in 1989 and is now in its
35th season how about that Norville has
been the face of Inside Edition for more
than two decades making her the longest
serving female news anchor on American
television Deborah Norville thank you
for joining us how are you doing yeah
the anniversary happy anniversary is
right did you hear that she said nine
hours after giving birth nine yeah this
was not my choice by the way the
producer called me up it was a woman at
the time you could have said no I could
have but she said Deb we're desperate we
have nobody I'm like really she said
would you come to the sidewalk and do
the wraps for the show we'll have you
upstairs I said do you remember the
outfits they give you yeah like open in
the back that's not happening got your
booty all out here's the thing if
hospitals would have a hair and makeup
person because I said I'll do it on one
condition you send hair and makeup an
hour before the camera crew I said okay
fine if it's okay with the hospital
which it was if hospitals would have a
hair and makeup person on the maternity
award staff they would get all the baby
business that's right it's so funny you
should say that because when I was
looking at the clip I went God your hair
and makeup looks so good I was actually
thinking that no we had professional
help but what a moment though yeah to
take people inside
um after giving birth do you look back
on that and you see what it what it did
for TV well I think what it did was just
just bring the audience closer in of
course you know I mean you guys create a
family here on CBS mornings and that's
what we try to do on Inside Edition our
family is me and our amazing
correspondents and the camera guys and
producers who put everything together
and I think when you share a moment like
that you know there was a time Gail when
you and I started where anything
personal was just it didn't happen yeah
it didn't have a personal life I think
that's been a healthy change both for
those of us who work in the business and
for people who watch our programs so 35
years of staying power do you think it's
that you're just so fabulous
in addition to you just being so
fabulous well my husband would say it's
because I'm so fabulous I think the show
has lasted 35 years because of the
consistency of what we do and that is
the consistency of variety it's never
the same thing we've always been really
consistent about trying to do
investigative stories where we years ago
when I started the show there had been a
minivan that had a flaw in the back lid
the back hatch that popped open in a
side impact Collision children were
dying we did a story about the faulty
latch they said they fixed it we did a
story about the fixed latch it wasn't
fixed we held people to account and I
think when people realize wow this
show's got my back we don't do it every
day but we do that kind of solid
journalism that helps people realize
that whoa Inside Edition is a show that
cares about the things that I care about
and when you create that kind of
connection people people trust you to do
the right thing well because you can do
the solid journalism real journalism the
entertainment you could do the
whack-a-doodle stuff oh we do yeah I
mean everything
umbrella if there is a water skiing
squirrel
and please let us know if you have a
squirrel that water skis we'd like to
the rate and shoot up after that time
you know you mentioned the latch of the
van but what really makes a good story
for inside oh that's a great question
um I think it's the same thing for for
any television story and actually I
learned it when I worked here at CBS
news on the one of the magazine shows
it's like you're walking down a corridor
you turn the corner and you see
something you didn't expect a good story
has emotion whether it's the
heartstrings of oh my gosh she just had
a baby she's in this the studio it's the
snake you just saw that creates a
visceral reaction every story has an
emotional button that gets touched in
the part of the viewer and then
hopefully before the story's over you
give the resolution okay now we're
seeing all these crazy things here we're
talking about singing yeah I did a music
video so just so did you oh yes ma'am
and and I didn't get to sing a song that
anybody else had written
Deborah I love looking at all the looks
only because at the time when you're on
TV you look back at you you're thinking
I look pretty good that was what you
were going for that day and I know and
then when you look at back on it when
you look at it today you go what was I
thinking what was I thinking yeah and
why did they let me go out there looking
like that you sort of want to share the
blame so you've got 35 years on the job
35 years in your marriage it's the same
anniversary which has been more
fulfilling more fun speaking to the
microphone it's marriage because you
know what I have a lifetime contract
with Carl wellner I have a however many
year contract with Inside Edition but I
think well especially because in a job
we'll all get that call you know we're
deciding to go in a different different
direction yes which does not include you
yes but the thing about
um I think how you last how TV show
lasts that long or how how a marriage
lasts that long is you don't take the
bait there are times when you could
tussle with somebody there are times
when you could get into it with your
great advice where you know what Take
the Long View yeah Let It Go like that
song Let It Go and it works yeah and
there's no commercial breaks in marriage
even though sometimes we wish there is
uh Deborah Norville thank you for
everything your contributions to Media
I'm Mrs Burleson he didn't mean that I
didn't mean I wasn't talking about you
baby thank you so much thank you we'll
be right back